okay
in this situation mike and i are an
intense situation and i take the
initiative because i know things are
getting bad
my idea is simply to strike him in the
face with the show manuji
going from low to high mike's clever and
with it he brings his hand up to protect
his face
now a lot of times i might want to move
to this back side here
but mike can easily stop me by moving
his hand wide so you see here
if i were to keep going forward might
wind up getting behind me this is a bad
day
so what i do when i feel that is i cut
out to the 45 degree angle and bring
this hand in
now by bringing this hand in you can see
he'll slide off of me so he can't hit me
in the face
and as this happens the arm is going to
go low i'm going to grab his thumb
with the hand that came in and it's the
inside of his wrist with the other hand
here i'm going to extend into mic so i'm
expressing culture here and we're
already getting mike into the shield
nugget position
i'm going to step through and turn from
this position i should nicely be behind
mike right
i don't want to be right next to my
theater weapon in this hand you can keep
it standing with it
so i come off to the side here i drive
him straight in
from here i drive my forearm into his
tricep and get the pin
one more time to speak